in my house
all right
hello everyone I'm sorry
so I will be here in the whole semester
and then after this I will start a
post-op position at Hebrew University
um today I will tell you about the
recent progress in vertex connectivity
and before that I want to introduce a
bit about my own research interests so
although I would have connectivity I'm
interested in combinatory optimization
problem generally on graph connectivity
Network design or flow problems and also
I'm very much interested in data
structure problems and I'm in particular
on the connection between amortized
analysis and the extreme combinatorics
and the con my favorite problem is
dynamic continuality conjecture which
involves something about the performance
of play trees and geometry of the Marine
resource tree and so on and I'm very
much uh like to work on this kind of
their contexture or troublesoft
contexture so we have some like recent
progress along this line so if you're
interested I can also share more about
this progress
and now so let's uh continue so let me
first Define the robotic quality problem
more formally so I gave you a graph
underrated graph with node and m-word M
M edges so we want to compute the
minimum number of vertices such that
when I remove from the graph I
disconnect the graph and for example in
this graph uh the connectivity is 2
because I can remove these two nodes to
disconnect the graph but I cannot delete
I've been going to disconnect the graph
and next I'm gonna
before I extend all the the survey of
the result I want to also mention the
the excite the list of collaborators in
this area so
first
so at least three of three of them are
present in this program
okay let me uh give you a survey of the
quick survey of the taxonomy problem so
the complexity it was like first started
in like 1969 by like kiteman and the
complexity is about mnk Square so so now
K you can think about K as like that
optimal the size of the optimal
separator and on the the column is just
when the graph is passed this is a
simplified complexity is quadratic and
what do we know in the literature so in
a really classic work they can also
improve the learning time to be
something out of this form in particular
square and with the randomization they
go ahead or managed to improve the
complexity to be in times key
and a bunch of the so there are some
recent progress some progress using a
specific specification by normal that
you can specify the edges to be uh only
order NK and
also some you can use there's also the
reduction to a matrix multiplication so
you can solve the technology using
matrix multiplication and some this this
monster state of the art due to high
singular and cable that give the
randomized algorithm that software
technology in M times n
and here is like the complete picture
before I started this problem so the
next one is uh
cables give the deterministic algorithm
that is quite almost MN but not quite MN
but the the challenge in this area when
I started was that if you look at the
special case when the graph is passed
then the complexity has been quadratic
so the the first goal if anything is
that we need to break this quadratic
barrier right to make progress with this
to this problem
yeah and also the at least uh alcohol
man also asks whether or not there's a
linear time but technology algorithm in
this area so it acts like almost 50
years ago
uh this is uh this is this is my work
for the event directed yeah yes even
directed
um I want to emphasize that you know
look at this that the runtime still and
then even if you we assume linear time
might flow so we still need something
more to to make progress on this and so
the first result that that like we we
show we saw that for small connectivity
we managed to make the quadratic barrier
in fact we can get up to like all almost
uh like
I wanted to mention that the key new
ingredient that make this progress
possible is like the the Paradigm of the
local computation and property testing
that was like introduced in this area
and then this allowed us to uh give the
Improvement and
just to say something I start to say a
few words about local computation so I
gave you a fixed node s and the question
is that is there a small unbalanced card
that contains s and then I want to be
able to detect this this card like in
sub-linear time so I don't want to read
the whole graph but I still want to be
able to decide this so this is the the
kind of question that enables us to make
progress in in a small connect vertex
connectivity
um
what I also want to highlight a bit that
like the algorithm is so simple that is
also implementable and then we also show
some experimental result that is
actually uh scalable
uh it's also you can run in in in real
world graphs
um
and
here the
social connectivity we know how to do it
near linear time but the question next
question is how about larger
connectivity what do we know about that
can we do anything better than MN
so for for this question so let me
refresh the Detonator in the context of
Mac flow computation so basically let me
introduce this subroutine called stablex
mean cut so this is also similar to the
variant edges I mentioned in the edge
version so I give you a two two node S
and T I want to compute the minimum
vertices that separate s and t right so
and then this problem can be also by a
Mac flow in Max flow time and then given
this subroutine you can also solve
vertex connectivity trivially by just
running all pair map flow and then you
just find the minimum so far so this is
the trivial option you can do n Square
Mac flow and there are some progress on
reduction a reducing number of Mac flow
so this is true to refresh the previous
iterator in the context of Mac flow and
then the best reduction was n n times
core or backflow a little better at all
and you know thought and then for the
small connectivity we know how to do
like almost linear time but for higher
connectivity the previous upcoming kind
of scale for high connectivity so
what uh the recent progress is that like
we also managed to get something of the
from that uh well technology can be
solved in poly logarithmic of Mac flow
but the algorithm is randomized and the
key tools that we introduce into this
area involved involve the kernelization
some sketching and static property and
also the use of isolating card number
from The Edge version we also adapted to
the vertex solution and because of the
recent breakthrough in Mac flow so now
we can also say that okay protest
continuity can be solved in almost
linear time and this answer open Problem
by alcohol and omen
now that's great with the Solarity now
can be solving of my flow and what else
what are the questions left so what
about the deterministic algorithm so I
will give you a quick survey on the
deterministic version of the because the
previous uh only lock my flow autism is
randomized
so what do we know about deterministic
algorithm so I just the one one key
motivation to study is that in in The
Sibling problem of its connectivity so
there are like much uh well studied much
mobile study than uh like we must well
understood compared to vertex
connectivity for example uh in Edge
Community as like this and give a survey
already that like we know how to do
randomized very long ago by Carter and
then later on there's also a way to like
do randomize totally uh in 14 and then
also very recently we can even know how
to De randomize on the way to graph
but forward text connected the context
the picture is different
um because
uh so this is a set of the vertex
connectivity this is randomized but the
the best deterministic algorithm is by
Gable to give the learning time of
something like n to the five 1.5 Mac
flow
main floor
or you can do uh enter the 1.5 Mac flow
or you can do K Square Mac Flow by like
things like even 25
and uh the state of the art opposite a
deterministic is that like M times n is
also an open question whether or not can
you get it in different musicality in in
content and only linear time algorithms
are known for very small connectivity
like the constant connectivity and then
there are some recent progress on on
this deterministic regime so let me
elaborate a bit so the recent progress
is that like last year what we know how
to do is like in almost linear time for
a very very small connectivity let's say
see if like K is like
we know how to do this and then there
are some very recent uh progress that we
know how to do in case Square Mac flow
and also the N Mac flow and I want to
emphasize that in Mac flow here it's
like
still fresh is still happening they're
in the workshop here so it's still uh
something coming up very exciting uh
progress is coming up and I want to uh
add a few keywords on this uh technique
that we developed along this line that
we for the first one we developed
something called vertex specifier and
you'll be usable to expander to make
this work for small connectivity and
then we do some usage of the terminal
reduction and definitely cut Lemma for
the K Square macro and then the the last
one like in in mag flow is to do the
randomization of the technique if in the
kernelization from the uh previous one
and I want to conclude with some
exciting open problem that I feel like
is also still uh we're still quite far
from it that determine can you do
different algorithm for the technology
like in near linear time can you do this
and we know how to do that for constant
complexity but it seems like super
difficult to get something better than
MN so whether or not you can you also
find some separate uh lower bound from
this that would be really really
interesting and I also want to mention
that directed is also open like if you
look at the direct connectivity then the
running time is either m c square or n
Square both are randomized and then if
you look at where the connectivity is
also by far that the running time of
weather connected is M times n
so either like making progress on this
area or like the establish some
conditional level bound it would be very
very interesting
for that I would like to conclude
[Applause]
any questions oh yes yeah if I'm your
student questions can you go back one
side
um so the uh for the actual activity the
last two let's see result uh
until one was
I mean I'm a bit confused about what is
better between the two so this one is
slightly lower than this one but uh this
one works for our event with on the web
oh so this is the main difference yeah
so this is like stronger in essence
it's a type of
is a type of directed expanded
composition you would like for this
problem related to the one that Jason
talked about uh if like undirected but
it's a expansion in the sense of robotic
experience I'm not very expensive so
it's slightly different but it's similar
yes
but this could be one of the ingredients
that you need to get the director
um
yeah but there's some some barrier on
the generalizing but it's classified
challenging but is the definition of
these things clear what it should be uh
yes yes it will defined
um I want you to see in the next the
last Slide the reference for okay the
reference for uh the weighted vertex
connectivity
yeah
yes
hasn't gotten
that is so these modern techniques
yeah yeah like the same size the thing
is that we have like all the Android
that doesn't seem to be usable for the
web so it's very interesting because in
the it's connectivity when you have the
weather drop it's very easy to do like a
sampling method to the internet thing
but when you have vertex then
then the same treatment
so it's very interesting if there's
something that can
do a background
foreign